foreign
we all know blockchain is one of the
major Tech stories of the past decade
everyone seems to be talking about it
but beneath the surface chatter there is
not always clear understanding of what
blockchain is so in this video we are
going to know what is blockchain and how
you can actually create your own
blockchain to understand the
fundamentals and the working of
blockchain hey everyone welcome to this
new video of Simply learn on how to
create your own blockchain before moving
ahead do subscribe to our YouTube
channel for more such interesting videos
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn also if you are
interested to learn more about
blockchain then you can check out our
blockchain course and actually learn and
gather information with our live classes
and Hands-On projects that will help you
build your base and reach higher levels
in your career moving on let's see what
is blockchain
hell blockchain allows for the permanent
immutable and transparent recording of
data and transaction this in turn makes
it possible to exchange anything that
has value whether it is a fiscal item or
something less tangible blockchain is a
technology that enables the sharing of
information data obviously stored in a
database transactions are recorded in an
account book called a ledger now a
blockchain is a type of distributed
database or Ledger one of the today's
top Trend which means that the power to
update a blockchain is distributed
between the nodes or participants of
that network but this raises a question
that how one can actually create their
own blockchain if you need a network for
it well let me tell you a basic
structure of blockchain now the
blockchain looks like this there is a
block where multiple transactions are
stored in one go which is known as data
but the block itself has its own
identity as an ID a hash number and a
previous hash number that actually to
represents the hash number of its
previous block now the first block in a
chain is known as Genesis block after
that whatever blocks get added to it
resumes the hash number of its previous
blog as a previous hash number and then
creates its own hash number and that's
how mining works so in this video we are
going to create the exact replica of
this blockchain
so let's quickly jump to the code I'm
using pycharm as my online compiler to
compile my code and get the output but
you can use any online or offline
compiler according to your desirable
coding language that you prefer I am
using python to code over here so first
we have to create a project uh I'm
giving my project name my blockchain and
then you have to
actually click on the create and your
project will be created
my project is already created that's why
I was not getting the create option so
let's start coding
so first we will create a blog and we
have to declare a class
and name it block
now we have to Define init function
we will also declare a hash and data
because that's what what is stored in a
Blog
previous hash number
and we have to input the data
self dot data is equals to data that's
how we have to declare every parameter
that we have declared in our init
function
and that's how our blog will be created
now that we know how to create a blog
now we have to create a blockchain and
for that we have to generate our hash
because without that uh we will not be
able to create a blockchain because
every Interlink block actually covers
the hash number of its previous block so
now we have to create a hash generator
now we have to declare hash generator
Library
that will help us generate the hash
number
and as We Know blockchain by default
uses sng 256 algorithm so
so that's
that's why we will pass our data
so what it will do it will convert
whatever data we have fed it into a
hexadecimal format
that we have
declared our hash generator library and
scj-256 to actually take code our data
into a hexadecimal form because as we
know our hash number will be generated
in that format
so we are converting it into a
hexadecimal format
so now we will create our own blockchain
so we'll create our own class with name
blockchain
so as we know the first block of the
blockchain is Genesis block so for that
we have to
input hash last number that will be the
previous hash number of the block
again we will use hash generator here so
by default we will declare our previous
hash number in our Genesis block by 0
because this is the first block and it
doesn't have any previous block to carry
on the previous hash number in its own
ID
now why we are using hash generator
to get the hexadecimal format of the
hash number
so now we will get the hash number of
last chain
and this is to generate the hash number
of that particular blog our Genesis
block one more thing every Blog has its
unique hash so you can see that even
though it has hundreds of thousands of
blocks attached to it it any hash number
won't be repeated every hash number is
unique
and that is to maintain the privacy of
the blockchain so that if anybody tries
to uh impact it via an ulterior motive
they won't be able to do so
now when we will be attaching another
block to this blockchain we will need
the hash number of Genesis block because
that will be the previous hash number
for the second block attached to it
so now our Genesis block is created now
we will create a chain for our Genesis
block
here we are creating the chain for our
Genesis block
so now our chain spot is created
now that we have to add every block we
will create another function under this
class
so here now we have the previous we need
the previous hash number of the Genesis
block
so chain
function to actually
retrieve the previous hash number of
Genesis block
and Interlink both the blocks together
so technically it's like an array where
we have our Genesis block already stored
so whatever data will be added at the
last its hash number will be
so whatever uh data will be stored at
the last its hash number will be
retrieved by the first block
now we have to generate this particular
blocks hash
by passing whatever data we are getting
also the last hash that we have
retrieved
so now whatever data we are passing we
want to make it unique so whatever data
we have passed through the blog
that will be added by the last hash
number like if you're adding the second
block the last hash number of the
Genesis proc will be added to it
and then we will send it to the hash
generator so that it will retrieve that
final data and create a hexadecimal
number
so one more thing we could have uh just
passed data or we could have just passed
previous hash number also through it it
was not needed to add it but we are
doing it to make the data unique so
whatever data is actually passed through
it and if we add it with the hexadecimal
we also eliminate the slightest chance
of making the hash numbers similar
so here again we are passing data hash
and previous hash
so like this we have added one more
block to our blockchain
so for now we have covered Genesis blog
and another blog that we wanted to
create to the Genesis block with its
previous hash number
and then we will attach it to the chain
so now whatever class we have created we
are going to use that
here we are going to use our blockchain
object in this variable
and through this we will pass our final
data
we will simply use this object to add
every block using the block class that
we have created
so I'm using this object uh to add the
first block with the ID a
so now we have created our first block
with the idea and like this I will
create two more blocks with IDP and C
copying it
pasting to create two other blocks with
idb and C
blocks are created now we have to change
them
so whatever block we have created we are
going to convert them into a format of
dictionary
so whatever blocks we have created we
are appending it to the chain that we
created previously
so this was our code for creating a
blockchain so now it's created now we
have to run this code
so now you can see it has generated
three blocks
block a Block B Block C now this is our
blockchain you can see it has its own
hash number and previous hash number
so we can see data gen data and hash and
previous hash this is the overall of the
blockchain now if we see clearly
you can see that the previous hash is
similar to the hash number of the
previous block
so here you can see the previous hash of
as by default now previous hash of B is
the hash number of c and the previous
hash of C is the hash number of B
so now we have got a hash number and
previous hash number so this proves that
we have created a blockchain
successfully
so this was just a small demonstration
but this gives you an idea that how
actually blockchain is created how
transactions are stored in it in a huge
level and how it actually maintains its
privacy so if you like this video then
please do share it with your friends and
family this was the code and you can use
it to add more blocks to it and if you
have any questions related to this code
or to this video you can feel free to
ask in a comment section and our team
will reach out to you as soon as
possible also do not forget to subscribe
to my YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon to never miss an update for more
such interesting videos thank you and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you